نبدا بتطورات في قطاع غزه حيث افاد
مراسلنا بسقوط عشره شهداء في قصف اسرائيلي
على مدرسه للاونروا تؤوي نازحين في حي
الرمال غرب غزه فجر اليوم واضاف مراسلنا
بسقوط شهداء وجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي مستمر
على حي الصبره بمدينه غزه ومعنا من مستشفى
الشفاء في مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل قربنا من اخر
التطورات لديك
نعم نحن نتحدث منذ ساعات امس او ليله امس
انما كان الحرب بدات من جديد وفي ساعه
الصفر قوات الاحتلال قصفت الكثير من
المنازل نتحدث بدايه من حي الشيخ رضوان
قرب مفترق اللبابيدي قوات الاحتلال قصفت
قرب قرابه ثلاث بنايات سكنيه بشكل كامل
على رؤوس ساكنيها وحتى هذه اللحظه العشرات
من الشهداء اسفل الانقاظ هذه المنطقه
الواقعه شمال منطقه شمال منطقه مدينه غزه
اما اذا ما تحدثنا عن منطقه مخيم الشاطئ
قوات الاحتلال قصفت منزلين منزلا لعائله
شاهين وهناك عشرات الشهداء ايضا في هذا
المنزل وما زال الاطفال اسفل الانقاظ
بالاضافه الى قصف منزل لعائله عقل هذا
المنزل ايضا وصل الى مستشفى الشفاء عدد
كبير من الاصابات بالاضافه الى شهدين من
هذا المنزل اما اذا ما انتقلنا الى منطقه
جنوب غرب مدينه غزه هذه المنطقه التي
تعرضت لقصف عنيف سواء من الطائرات الحربيه
او من مدفعيه قوات الاحتلال بالتزامن مع
تقدم هذه الاليات حتى ايضا من زوارق
الحربيه كان هناك قصف عنيف جدا على هذه
المنطقه هذه المنطقه بجوارها منطقه تل
الهواء ومنطقه الجمعات وتجمع لمدارس
الانور و قوات الاحتلال قصفت بشكل كثيف
مما ادى الى سقوط عره شهداء داخل مدرسه
تتبع للنور في حي الرمال اما اذا ما
تحدثنا عن منطقه الصبره ومنطقه جنوب
الرمال هذه المنطقه التي قصفت بها شقه
سكنيه تتبع لعائله شرفا سقط وارتقى خلالها
ثلاثه شهداء وبقيت ج جثامينهم في تلك
المنطقه بالاضافه الى ذلك قوات الاحتلال
مع التزامن بالتقدم الى مدينه غزه من
منطقه حي النصر قصفت اسعافي وارتقى عدد من
المسعفين وحتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف ما هي
هذه الجثث ومن هم المتواجدين داخل هذه
الاسعافات وحتى المسعفين الذين كانوا
متواجدين داخل الاسعافات بعض المصادر
تحدثت عن ان قوات الاحتلال قد تكون انتشلت
جثمان واحتجزتهم واحتجزتهم لديها العمليه
العسكريه بدات من جديد بدايه من شمال
مدينه غزه دخولا في حي النصر وصولا الى
مفترق العائلات المقابل الى مستشفى الشفاء
تزامن هذا الدخول من المنطقه الجنوبيه
منطقه مفترق الجامعات ومنطقه تله الهواء
ومنطقه الاتصالات وحتى هذه اللحظه قوات
الاحتلال تتمركز في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه او او وسط
مدينه غزه في مدينه عرفات التابعه للشرطه
الفلسطينيه قوات الاحتلال بالتزامن مع
وصول الى حي النصر الذي يبعد قرابه ال 100
متر عن مستشفى الشفاء طائرات الكواد كابتر
اطلقت الكثير من الرصاص بالاضافه الى ان
قوات الاحتلال اطلقت عشرات الرصاصه
من دبابات قوات الاحتلال التي تمركزت على
بعد امطار من مستشفى الشفاء نحن الان
نتحدث عن وضع كارثي ووضع خطير جدا داخل
مستشفى الشفاء في ظل نزوح عائلات العائلات
التي تتواجد داخل المستشفى بالاضافه الى
نزوح الاطباء وهروبهم من هذا الخطر
المتكرر قوات الاحتلال يبدو انها تكرر
التجربه في كافه المستشفيات باسقاط القطاع
الصحي واسقاط ما حاولت وزاره الصحه ترميمه
خلال الفتره القادمه من تشغيل غرف عمليات
من اعاده تشغيل بعض المولدات من اعاده
تشغيل بعض الاقسام لكن الوضع خطير جدا
الان نحن نتحدث عن تحليق مكثف للطيران
وقصف العشرات المنازل الوحدات الدفاع
المدني ووحدات الاسعاف لا تستطيع التحرك
في هذا في هذا الوضع الان اذا ما تحدثنا
عن تمركز قوات الاحتلال والدخول تحدثنا
فيما قبل ان منطقه حي النصر مرورا بالشارع
بشكل كامل وفي الحي بشكل كامل لم يستطع
المواطنون التحرك في تلك الليله ولم ي في
هذا الخطر الكبير نتحدث الان عن تمركز
لقوات الاحتلال من جديد في منطقه عرفات
الواقعه جنوب مدينه غزه بالاضافه الى
منطقه انصار ايضا الواقعه جنوب مدينه غزه
قبل ايام قليله قوات الانسحاب قوات
الاحتلال انسحبت من تلك المنطقه لكن يبدو
ان قوات الاحتلال تعيد الكره مره اخرى في
اسقاط كما تحدثت الوض الوضع الصحي نتحدث
عن حاله خطيره وكارثه بالتزامن مع دخول
قوات الاحتلال هناك عدد من العائلات
محاصره
ومحتجزة في تلك المنطقه بكثافه ولا نعرف
ماهيه او مصير هذه العائلات حتى هذه
اللحظه طيب اسماعيل ونحن نتابع معك يبدو
ان الطقس ايضا يضغط اكثر كيف تفاقم هذه
الظروف المناخيه معاناه الغزيين وبالخصوص
النازحين الذين فقدوا
[موسيقى]
بيوتهم نعم نحن نتحدث عن خوف كبير قبل
المعاناه قوات الاحتلال قصفت عدد من
المنازل المجاوره لمستش شفا الشفاء مما
اثر على حركه النزوح هذا المكان الذي
اعتبر ماوى كبير للكثير من العائلات تاوت
في داخل مستشفى الشفاء خاصه ان مستشفى
الشفاء متسع لكثير من العائلات قرابه ال 3
ال شخص كان كانوا يتواجدون داخل مستشفى
الشفاء هروبا من القصف الاسرائيلي وهروبا
ايضا من الطقس الشديد بعد تدمير قوات
الاحتلال بيوتهم الان هذه العائلات تضطر
راغمه الى الهروب الى مدارس واماكن الواء
المدمر ايضا لاعاده افتتاحها والتعايش مع
هذا الوضع الصعب لكن الان هذا الطقس يؤثر
بشكل جلي الكثير من الاطفال لا يمتلكون
ملابس ولا يمتلكون اغطيه كافيه في ظل حاله
القصف المتكرر واح واحراق قوات الاحتلال
الكثير من المنازل تضطر العائلات على الت
التموضع او عفوا التعايش مع بعض الاغطيه
البسيطه يضطرب بالعائله التخلي عن الغطاء
من اجل ان يدفئ اسرته الان حتى الوضع على
مستوى اشعال النيران الوضع خطير جدا قوات
الاحتلال كل من يشعل النار في بعض المناطق
يتم قصفه فلذلك العائلات وحتى الحطب لا
تواجد بشكل وفير في منطقه شمال قطاع غزه
فتضطر العائلات الى التعايش مع هذا الواقع
الصعب قبل ايام وصل طفل الى مستشفى الشفاء
توفى اثر البرد كان هذا الطفل لا يبلغ
ايام من عمره وهذه الحاله التي يعيشها
الكثير من اطفال قطاع غزه في ظل البرد
الشديد شكرا لك سم